Joker definitely goes its own way with
the depiction of the legendary Clown
Prince of Crime right up to its
explosive and unforgettable climax now
that everyone's had a chance to see the
film it's time to talk about what it all
built to and how it all paid off
spoilers ahead for the entire film the
whole of Joker is about the
transformation of Arthur Fleck from down
trodden beat up loser to hero in his own
mind sometimes literally in his own mind
the last time we see Arthur he's walking
out of an interview room at Arkham State
Hospital fresh off the triumphs of the
night he shot Murray Franklin and became
the figurehead of an entire riotous
movement we see our thirdly bloody
footprints as he dances down the hall
and then we see an orderly chasing him
down the corridors suggesting a violence
escape might be an order for the
newly-minted Clown Prince of Crime the
film makes it clear several times that
Arthur black is a man who has no trouble
losing himself in elaborate fantasies
but the question of what's fact or
fantasy doesn't actually change the
outcome for Arthur Fleck by the end of
Joker whether he's escaping to a new
life of crime or caught in a delusion
it's clear that he's long since passed
the point of no return one of the most
important structural aspects of Joker is
just how small Arthur's inner circle is
he has his mother of course and he
seemingly has friends at the clown
company until they begin to turn on him
but apart from that and the only major
presence left is Sophie his neighbor who
we actually know less about than some
parts of the film would have us believe
in Arthur's mind Sophie is his
girlfriend at least until she isn't in
Sophie's mind Arthur is just the
slightly strange neighbour she and her
daughter ride the elevator with
sometimes when he walks into her
apartment uninvited and we discover his
fantasy life with her she is clearly
scared but also eager to defuse the
situation so what becomes of Sophie it's
hard to say but what's clear is that the
police will soon be finding a brutally
murdered body in Arthur's apartment so
they'll probably be knocking on her door
to ask questions at which point she'll
discover just how lucky she was
throughout the film as Arthur goes
through his own deeply personal descent
into violent vengeful madness a massive
groundswell of support for him is
building right under his nose near the
end of the film
Arthur promises Murray Franklin that
he's a political he says that he has
nothing to do with the protesters who
have adopted clown masks in solidarity
with the then
I'm a subway shooter but he's clearly
pleased by the idea that people had
begun to idolize him in some way by the
end of the film arthur has fully
embraced the people who have become his
followers standing up among them as a
leader for one triumphant moment before
the film cuts to him in Arkham
so whether Arthur stays in Arkham state
hospital or not the Joker gang will
simply not calm down and go home
they might dissipate or relax their
protest a bit and eventually fade out
but that doesn't just go away because
the Joker is in jail he was simply the
face they adopted for their own social
unrest
the gang is still out there and they
might still be causing vast amounts of
chaos Arthur's explorations of his
mother's true motives as she obsessively
writes letters to Thomas Wayne take him
on an emotional roller coaster he
initially only sees Wayne as his
mother's former employer and penny
confesses that Wayne is his father
Thomas Wayne and his Butler Alfred deny
this and Arthur later seemingly confirms
their denials after stealing his
mother's records from Arkham and
confirming that he was adopted but is
that the whole truth after he kills his
mother Arthur finds an old photo of her
with an inscription on the back signed
by TW so perhaps Thomas Wayne is not
Arthur's father but had an affair with
Arthur's adoptive mother or did it go
down like penny insisted the whole
adoption story was a cover-up for what
really happened we can't say for sure
but that little inscription suggests
that there's more to the story than
those our compiles had to offer
Joker spends much of its run time
dodging potential comic book connections
when those connections do kick in though
they lead down a dark path a chain
reaction started by Arthur that ends in
the murder of Thomas and Martha Wayne
one of the final images of the film is
Bruce Wayne standing alone in that same
alley the bodies of his parents on
either side of him it's an image that
Arthur laughs at and the film suggests
that he'll hold on to that image going
forward as bruce wayne grows up the big
question that the film doesn't answer
though is how seen a clown shoot his
parents will end up changing Bruce
Batman is usually depicted as a guy who
fights criminals in general but this
version of Bruce might end up having a
very specific agenda on his hands when
he's all grown up one that would
fundamentally alter the Dark Knight's as
we know him very early on in Joker
when Arthur comes home to relax in front
of the TV with his mother at the end of
the day we see the first traces of the
fantasy life he leads as he
imagines himself in the studio audience
of Murray Franklin's show later the film
shows us that this fantasy can go much
much deeper this is all important
because it emphasizes just how lonely
and unstable Arthur is it's also
important because it forces us to
contend with a possibility that at least
some of what Arthur does during the
film's climax didn't actually happen was
he really carried out of the cop car by
his followers after the crash
did he really murder his therapist does
it go deeper was he really in the asylum
the whole time just imagining all of
this is that why the colors of his
clothes always matches Arkham's decor
these are questions that encourage
repeat viewing of the film to see just
how many details point to the reality or
fantasy of each scenario Joker is among
many other things the origin story for a
villain even if it's not the same
version of the villain were used to
seeing on the comic book page or even on
the big screen by the end of the film
Arthur Fleck is directly asking people
to call him Joker and drawing a big
smile on his face and his own blood
seems to seal the deal
he's the Joker now when you bring me out
can you introduce me as Joker but
there's also no mystery over the Joker's
identity this time around so how can we
reconcile him with the comic book
version well the short answer is we
don't have to and the film doesn't
really want us to but if you're really
interested in digging that deep there
are a couple of possibilities one is
that this is just another version of the
many fake origin stories that Joker
likes to throw around to confuse people
the other is that Arthur Fleck is not
the only Joker and that one day perhaps
when Bruce Wayne is all grown up a
mystery man will adopt the moniker with
Arthur as the inspiration then again
maybe it was all a dream
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]